ship and courage
or an inspiration to all of us
I am pleased that he could join our
meeting today
president zelinski made clear that
Ukraine relies on our continued support
and our message to him was equally clear
Ukraine can count on us
for as long as it takes
allies will continue to provide a major
military and financial help
and today leaders agreed
to strengthen our support by agreeing a
comprehensive assistant package for
Ukraine
this includes secure Communications fuel
medical supplies and body armor
equipment to counter mines and chemical
and biological threats and hundreds of
portable anti-drone systems
over the longer term
we will help Ukraine transition from
soviet-era equipment
to Modern NATO equipment boost
interoperability
and further strengthen its defense and
security institutions
all of these shows our commitment to
Ukraine's future and that our commitment
is unshakable
a strong independent Ukraine is vital
for the stability of the Euro Atlantic
area
today at the summit NATO lead is decided
a fundamental shift in our defense and
deterrence to respond to a new security
reality
we will strengthen our forward defenses
we will enhance our bad groups in the
eastern part of the alliance
opt to be grade levels
we will transform the NATO response
force and increase the number of high
redness forces to well over 300
000.
we will also boost our ability
to reinforce
including with more pre-positioned
equipment and stockpiles of military
supplies
more forward deployed capabilities like
air defense
strengthen command and control
and upgraded defense plans with forces
pre-assigned to defend specific allies
this is the first time since the cold
war that we have this kind of plans with
the pre-assigned forces
they will work with Home Defense Forces
and become familiar with local terrain
facilities and pre-positioned stocks
so that we can reinforce even faster
doing more will cost more
today allies
recommitted to the pledge we made in
2014.
to spend at least two percent of GDP on
the fence
since 2014 European allies and Canada
have spent the next round 350 billion US
dollars
nine allies
now reach or exceed the two percent
targets 19 allies have clear plans to
reach it by 2024.
and an additional five have concrete
commitments to meet it thereafter
two percent is increasingly seen as the
floor not as a ceiling
allies are also investing more in modern
capabilities
contributing more to Nato deployments
and exercises and we have agreed to
increase NATO's common funding
to finance to finance the facilities we
need for reinforcement
as well as more training and more
exercises command and control and
engagement with partners
we Face a radical change
to our security environment
and strategic competition is rising
around the world
so today leaders have endorsed NATO's
new strategic concept
and it is published as we speak and this
is the new strategic concept the current
one was agreed in 2010 and this is very
different compared to what we agreed
back then
it makes clear that Russia's Russia
poses the most significant and direct
threat to our security
in the current concept we state that
Russia is a strategic partner
in the current concept we do not mention
China with a single word in this allies
states that China's currency policies
challenge our interests security and
values